ich würde gerne nochmal die grippe und
cupid 19 ein wenig vergleichen
beide krankheiten sind besonders für
ältere und chronisch kranke menschen
gefährlich beide krankheiten greifen die
lunge an menschen die schwer erkranken
müssen ins krankenhaus manche müssen
sogar auf die intensivstation und
beatmet werden
wichtige unterschiede sind aber das
kogit 19 im vergleich zur grippe zu mehr
schweren erkrankungen und zu mehr
todesfällen führt und auch teilweise zu
leiden die noch monatelang andauern
können nachdem die akute infektion
abgeklungen ist
wenn also viele cupid 19 fälle und viele
grippefälle gleichzeitig auftreten dann
befürchten wir dass das
gesundheitssystem überlastet werden kann
unser ziel ist es deshalb zu wenig cupid
19 infektionen wie möglich und so wenig
grippe infektionen wie möglich und wir
haben gute chancen das zu erreichen und
wir alle können ja dazu beitragen
wie können wir alle dazu beitragen
sie kennen die asl regeln abstand halten
hygieneregeln beachten alltags masken
tragen und lüften oder die empfehlung
sich mit anderen menschen eher an der
frischen luft zu treffen als in
geschlossenen räumen auf diese weise
kann man kuschelt 19 infektionen
verhindern aber genausogut
grippeinfektionen und bei der grippe
kommt ein ganz entscheidender aspekt
dazu es gibt schon seit vielen
jahrzehnten einen impfstoff die impfung
wirkt aber nicht bei allen geimpften
gleich gut aber sie ist tatsächlich der
beste schutz vor der krankheit den wir
haben jedes jahr werden durch die
impfung 100.000 hunderttausende grippe
fälle verhindert im schnitt in
deutschland etwa 400.000 grippe fälle
pro jahr
und wenn menschen die gegen grippe
geimpft sind trotzdem erkranken dann
erkranken sie in der regel nicht zu
schwer
wir haben also mit der grippeimpfung ein
wirklich mächtiges instrument in der
hand
und wenn es uns gelingt dass sich in
diesem jahr mehr gefährdete menschen
gegen grippe impfen lassen und wenn alle
die asl regeln auch beherzigen dann
können wir die grippewelle flach halten
und dass das auch möglich ist und das
ist wirklich etwas was sehr optimistisch
und stimmt das zeigt ein blick auf die
südhalbkugel dieser welt auf australien
neuseeland südafrika oder südamerika
dort findet die grippewelle
normalerweise von juli bis september
statt also in unserem sommer in diesem
jahr ist die grippewelle in diesen
bereichen aber praktisch ausgefallen
wahrscheinlich in erster linie weil sich
die menschen an kontakt beschränkungen
gehalten haben
deshalb bitte ich sie beherzigen sie
weiter die asl regeln und wenn sie einer
risikogruppe angehören oder zu
medizinischen personal gehören
bitte lassen sie sich zusätzlich zur
einhaltung dieser regeln auch gegen
grippe impfen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren